do you have anything to say do you have
anything to say any any apologies at all
no words just a nod of apology after
these two police officers admitted
taking unofficial photographs of a
murder scene
pc denise jaffa and pc jamie lewis were
asked to guard the area where sisters
biba henry and nicole smallman were
found dead in bushes they'd been having
fun celebrating bibba's birthday in
friend park in north london when they
were attacked by daniel hussein
rather than protecting the crime scene
police officers jaffa and lewis left
their post to take photographs and
shared them on whatsapp
shocking details of how the police
officers behaved has now emerged pc
lewis edited one of the pictures and
superimposed his own face on the photo
with the two victims in the background
he then shared this with pc jaffa who
sent it on unsolicited to a female
officer
for the family and friends of the
murdered sisters this crime has brought
added trauma
marmina has called on the metropolitan
police to take control
if you've got a rotten piece of fruit in
a book a fruit bowl it contaminates
everything around it
so we need to drill down
and get the rot out once and for all
and if these police officers do not get
a custodial sentence it will not send
the message
you are not above the law
the convictions come a week after
criticism of the lackluster response by
the met when the sisters were reported
missing
and at a time when the forces actions
are already under intense scrutiny
commissioner christa dick under pressure
to resign said in a statement
what former pc jaffa and pc lewis chose
to do that day was utterly
unprofessional disrespectful and deeply
insensitive i know that is the view of
colleagues across the met who utterly
condemn this behavior
the police officers will be sentenced in
early december with a warning from the
judge they should expect time behind
bars charlotte lomas sky news